it's about what you bring to it
obviously but so much of it is about who
you're interacting with and that can be
other actors the writers producers
director the crew you know everybody has
some sort of influence in some way
that's what's been such a joy about
playing the character over the course of
10 11 years is working with different
directors and seeing what different
directors expect one to a pull out of
the character you know we had built this
incredible world with Kenneth Brenner
and I think we really nailed the sort of
vulnerability in the fish out of water
and this this individual coming to terms
with who he was and what his place in
the world was and and then with taika
waititi it was about doing something
different and unexpected and so we
really dismantled the world we
dismantled the character we put him in a
very different place and environment
than he'd been in the past we changed
his look a dramatic haircut which was
you know a risk to the the comic book
fans for a minute